Happy New Year to everybody I hope your
new year is starting off great so far if
it hasn't I hope it gets extremely
better for you it only seems fitting
that we kick off the new year the first
video of the new year talking about the
new Avengers team and you might be kind
of surprised to hear like I was that
right now the new Avengers team does not
have characters on it like Spider-Man or
Thor and even more characters that we're
going to go over in this video but of
course there's a good explanation of why
they are not a part of the team but it
doesn't mean that some of these
characters won't still show up in
Avengers 5 so let's dive into these new
reports that we are hearing today also
I'll be announcing the winner of
December's giveaway tomorrow so stay
tuned for our video and of course we're
kicking off a new monthly giveaway for a
chance to win a PS5 and Xbox series X
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
all you have to do is subscribe and
leave a comment down below the winner
picks one item and we pick one winner at
the end of each month it does continue
on this year so to start this video off
unfortunately we have to mention the bad
news first Alex Perez over at the cosmic
circus.com who is an incredibly reliable
Insider has tweeted a lot of Scoops for
the new year we appreciate that Alex but
one of them is this Avengers 5 is not
coming out in 2026 there is still much
work to be tended to and too much to be
set up before they can dive deep into
the upcoming Avengers movie now of
course this is super unfortunate but
a lot of us really saw this coming
Avengers 5 was supposed to be Avengers
King Dynasty well Jonathan major who
played King the Conqueror was just found
guilty of two cases of harassment and
now Marvel Studios has let him go also
side note I've heard some people state
that some of these athlets who said he
was fired didn't actually hear this from
Marvel or Disney but I can personally
say that it is true I have spoken to
Disney and they have confirmed he is
fired they are moving away from Jonathan
major as king the Conqueror they didn't
comment on anything else like if they're
going to recast him or anything like
that but they did confirm to me that he
is fired now insiders have told us that
they are planning to recast him which
does make sense why abandon the story of
Kang when you're already halfway into it
but now that this has happened and they
have to recast and they have to kind of
change the story and we've heard that
Avengers 5 is no longer King Dynasty
well that means that Marvel Studios has
a lot to do for the next Avengers film
so it doesn't surprise us at all that
this movie is not going to be coming out
when it's supposed to come out it's
unfortunate but I would rather have them
get a really good story down for the
movie and have the movie be really
really good but Alex Perez continues and
he stated if the Avengers were to team
up tomorrow I guess the team would
consist of Captain America Captain
Marvel Falcon Hulk Wong Valkyrie shangqi
ktie Ant-Man and the WASP now let's talk
about this team for a second obviously
you can hear that some of these
characters that you thought would be a
part of the new Avengers team are not a
part of the new Avengers team and Alex
Press goes on to explain why but let's
talk about this current lineup this is
pretty much who you would expect to be
on the new team Sam Wilson's Captain
America Captain Marvel of course the new
Falcon who will be introduced in Captain
America Brave New World who is going to
be waen Torres who was introduced to us
in the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
Hulk makes sense he's been an Avenger
for a while he's one of the OG Avengers
Wong makes sense because he is the
sorcerer Supreme Valkyrie makes sense as
well because she is the king of new
Asgard which is on Earth right now so if
there's going to be an Earthly attack it
would make sense that she would be there
with the other Heroes to defend it
shangi and Katie kind of makes sense it
makes sense that shangi is there and
after all shangi was there with Wong at
the end of shangi and the legend of the
tin Rings Katie was there as well but
she doesn't exactly have any powers
although she has become rather good with
a bow it looks like she's kind of the
only anomaly here don't get me wrong I
loved her character I think she's
hilarious but still no powers and I
should say no training because
characters like black Black Widow and
Hawkeye don't have powers but they have
extensive training and then to top it
all off Antman and the WASP it makes
sense that they were there they just
dealt with King the Conqueror and even
if Avengers 5 isn't going to be about
King they still fought King they still
fought a multiversal threat that should
still be a part of the story even if
Kang isn't going to be the villain of
Avengers 5 recent reports said that
Marvel Studios plans to kind of sweep
King under the rug for the time being
meaning they want things to kind of
fizzle out before they start mentioning
him again and putting him on screen and
I understand that however you can't just
act like what happened already didn't
happen especially if you are planning to
indeed have Kang still be the main
villain of the Multiverse Saga at the
end so I would really prefer for them to
not act like it didn't happen but to
bring in another villain in the meantime
and then get back to Kang but as far as
those missing Avengers that we thought
were going to be a part of the Avengers
5 roster Alex Perez goes on to explain a
little he says why Spidey Thor Daredevil
and Doctor Strange are not on the team
he simply said this Spider-Man wait for
Spider-Man 4 Thor wait for Thor 5
Daredevil wait for Spider-Man 4 and
Doctor Strange is involved with Clea in
another dimensioned and I really won't
expect him to show up for Avengers 5 if
Doctor Strange 3 pans out as I'm told it
will pan out side note he does say I
expect everyone and their mother for
Secret Wars but what I'm giving everyone
is the current lineup available for the
Avengers and Avengers 5 if it happened
tomorrow notice how it's unbelievably
underwhelming and lacking in members
which is why the film in question is
getting delayed now he does go on to
kind of further elaborate about some of
this he says Spidey is disconnected
following the events of no way home and
what happens in Spider-Man 4 but he'll
be there for Avengers 5 this sort of
implies that although Spider-Man might
be in the movie and in fact in fact
we've heard that he is going to be the
lead of Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 even
though he might be in the movie he won't
maybe be a part of the official roster
for the Avengers and since after no way
home nobody really knows who Peter
Parker is maybe the Avengers have a hard
time trusting him since they only know
Spider-Man and not who is under the mask
and even if they knew it was Peter
Parker they don't know who Peter Parker
is anymore but Alex Perez is implying
that a lot is going to happen in
Spider-Man 4 that leads to Spider-Man
not being officially a part of the
Avengers 5 roster the same thing goes
with Daredevil who we know was showing
up in Spider-Man 4 as well but it is
nice to know that he still confirms that
he will show up in the movie still he
will still show up in Spider-Man 5 but
what is very interesting is that now it
looks like Spider-Man 4 is going to
release before Avengers 5 whereas before
we heard that it was probably going to
come out between Avengers King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars but now it's
coming out before Avengers King Dynasty
or as we're calling it now Avengers 5
now as far as Thor not being a part part
of the Avengers team and Avengers 5 Alex
P says wait for Thor 5 to happen then we
will understand why he's not a member of
the official roster and I would assume
that Thor after Avengers 5 and possibly
during Avengers 5 is going to be off in
the cosmos somewhere doing something
that is related to taking down the main
villain of the Multiverse perhaps he is
out there trying to find the Council of
Kings or perhaps he is trying to find
some Cosmic entities or some Gods
possibly if Hercules is still the plan
for Thor 5 and he's going up against him
the gods are still going to be involved
in some way shape or form plus not to
mention he is of course a God himself
this is kind of what Thor did in the
past with the Infinity Stones he went
out and he was seeking to find more
knowledge about what exactly was
happening sounds like something pretty
similar is going to be happening with
Thor and Thor 5 and the next Avengers
film and Chris Hemsworth has already
mentioned that if he does another Thor
film which is already confirmed to be in
development at Marvel Studios he wants
it to be a different tone he wants it to
be more serious and this sounds like a
perfect story line the entire fate of
the entire Multiverse to get serious
about and notice Alex does not say that
he will show up in Avengers 5 at all so
Thor might be missing from The Avengers
5 film now for Daredevil he stated wait
for Spider-Man 4 to see what happens
with Daredevil and why he doesn't show
up in Avengers 5 as part of the official
roster so clearly something happens in
Spider-Man 4 which is said to be
somewhat of a civil war storyline that
makes it to where Daredevil is not a
part of the official Avengers team now
we assume Daredevil is going to be on
the side of Spider-Man but anything can
happen in this movie and since we
haven't really heard anything about
Daredevil and Spider-Man 4 yet our
speculation would be just that
speculation but if you have any theories
let us know your thoughts down below and
last but certainly not least the one who
seems to kind of be at the center of it
all right now is Doctor Strange now I've
done a few videos about what the
possible lineup for Avengers 5 could be
and I've never put Doctor Strange on
those lineups because of the exact
reason that Alex P States here he's
going to be involved with Clea in
another Dimension now we've heard a
little bit about Doctor Strange 3 so far
and apparently it's going to introduce
the group The Black priests the black
priests are a multiversal group in the
comics who sought out to protect the
Multiverse however they did this by
removing extraneous Earths from the
Multiverse so some view them as villains
and they have become more of anti-heroes
especially since Doctor Strange joined
them and became a leader of them now
this of course is coming from the story
in the comics what we've heard about
Doctor Strange 3 it's going to be a
little bit different from what we've
heard Clea is going to be a member of
the black priests and the black priests
have decided that doctor strange and all
of his variants and different universes
are the real threat of the Multiverse
which is something that was briefly
touched on in Multiverse of Madness
where Mr Fantastic said the greatest
threat to the Multiverse is you
referring to Doctor Strange so that's
what we know about it so far will Doctor
Strange go on to become the leader of
the black priests that could definitely
be possible since that happens in the
comics but needless to say it seems like
he's pretty tied up right now and that's
why we probably won't see him in
Avengers 5 but keep in mind like Alex P
said this is as of right now if Marvel
Studios goes on to change things which
we're hoping that they do then this
roster could very easily change but let
us know in the comments do you like this
roster so far or would you like it to
change and if so how would you change it
who would you add who would you take out
let us know all your thoughts please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things happening in the MCU you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter if you'd
like and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof